les incidents du stade de france samedi
soir à l'occasion du match de football
france algérie il ya eu la marseillaise
sifflée par plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de spectateurs et puis ces
supporters envahissant le terrain à la
fin du match qui empêche ce qui a
empêché que le match ne se termine
normalement nous voulons revenir
maintenant sur l'ensemble de ces
éléments pour mieux essayer de les
comprendre et voir quelles sanctions
peuvent être prises contre le stade de
france pour ne pas avoir assuré la
sécurité de cette rencontre enquête
julien beaumont sylvain doba et nathalie
gallet la marseillaise sifflée
il n'y a pas que les bleus qui ont été
choquées ce france algérie devait être
un match historique ce n'est pas ce
qu'on retiendra nasser sandjak ancien
sélectionneur de l'équipe algérienne ce
soit que ce fut la mort 16 6
c'est pas logique selon lui on va pas me
rappeler le contrat je crois que sur tes
traces autant que le deuxième fois sur
un produit commun soient revues lettre
les algérois n'ont toujours pas digéré
les images du match
la désillusion était la hauteur de
l'espérance qu'avait suscitée cette
rencontre je ne sais pas bien que c'est
honteux c'est vous
[Musique]
76e minute de jeu mikaël silvestre donne
son maillot pour échapper aux supporters
qui viennent d'envahir la pelouse devant
c'est le poignet d'inconscient qui
gâchent la fête
il y en tuera lui laisse exploser sa
colère un puits de 50 cents spectateurs
viennent d'envahir le terrain les forces
de sécurité sont débordés larbitre
arrête la rencontre la france mène 4 1
mille deux cents stadiers mobilisés pour
l'occasion c'est 50% de plus que
d'habitude
insuffisant au sol des objets dangereux
qui ne devrait pas être là la fédération
française de football
appelle en renfort les gendarmes mobiles
au stade de france on admet avoir été
dépassé mais on assume les choix n'a pas
suffi bon ça passe suffit il fallait il
aurait fallu mettre les grilles il
aurait fallu mettre plus de saint dié il
aurait fallu mettre plus de stadiers
mais avec le risque d'avoir des bagarres
en bas sur la pelouse
il aurait fallu mettre de la force
publique mais alors vous mettez la force
publique
vous arrêtez tout de suite le match
terrain suspendu à monde
c'est ce que risque le stade de france
la fifa étudie en ce moment le dossier
les décisions ne seront pas connus avant
le mois de novembre